-We're hanging out with
Barbra Streisand, everybody!
"Release Me" --
"Release Me 2" is out now.
Barbra, there's a rumor that
I wanted to ask you about
because we've talked about this
when you've been on the show
for years, and you said, "Oh, I
might be working on a memoir."
And everyone clapped and they
go, "Oh, that's amazing."
Then you came on
like two years later.
We talked, and you go, "And then
I'm also working on a memoir,"
and everyone clapped.
-Right.
-Were you lying to me or are you
working on this memoir?
-No, no, no, no.
Actually, I started writing
things down in longhand
in my journals, you know,
like these kinds of things.
I have like 20 of them,
which helped me write the book,
but I was always busy
doing something else,
so I would write in the journals
and then go on
to something else.
Actually, in 1984,
Jackie Kennedy came to me
and said, "I'd love to be
the editor of your book
at Doubleday," and we had tea.
She was just so lovely
and she -- but I wasn't ready
to do that then, but I did
start writing in my journals,
and in 1999,
I really started writing,
and then other things and
concerts and movies or whatever.
And then in 2008,
I really started writing.
-Yes.
-What year is it now?
-Now it's 2021, Barbra.
[ Laughter ]
-2021.
-Yeah. What do you think?
-Fortunately, the pandemic
helped me finish the book.
I'm almost finished.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-No. This is what happened
last time!
Almost finished? How almost?
-No, I've written 824 pages.
And I still have
the little epilogue to do.
And, you know, interesting --
my favorite number,
because I was born on the 24th,
is 24.
This book is now 824 pages.
-Wow.
-And it's 411,811,
something like that,
which if you add the numbers
together, they come up to 24.
-Wow.
-So it must be the right time
to release it.
-Alright, so it's -- Wow.
Alright, so that's basically
saying it's coming out.
-It's coming out --
Yeah, next year.
-Okay.
-Soon.
-How about a Barbra Streisand
biopic?
Would you be interested in that?
-No! No, no, no, no.
That's for when you're gone.
Somebody wants to play you.
I don't know.
I don't want to see that.
[ Laughter ]
I'm alive. I'm alive.
I'm still here.
-I know, but everyone is
doing it now.
It's kind of a thing.
People are doing it.
-So I won't do it now.
-Alright, perfect. Yeah.
-Everybody else is doing it,
not me.
-How about, like, a documentary
about you?
-Yes, you know, I've been
working on a documentary.
I mean, over the years
we have at least --
Oh, we have about six hours
already,
but I haven't had time
to finish it.
-Yeah, I understand.
-I don't watch my movies
and I don't watch
my television specials
and I don't listen to
my records.
-You should do all of them
because they're all fantastic.
You really are amazing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I love you.
The album is out now,
"Release Me 2."
Barbra, I hope to get to see you
in person next time, please.
-Thank you.
Thank you for showing me that.
-I love you, buddy.